[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya de la puissance dans la
simplicité
je me suis réveillé ce matin fin stress
il ya un tête voilà là c'est super
sérieux
j'étais comme ça et puis je me dis bon
alors peut-être faut que j'avais fait un
jogging aux biens en faudrait que je
fasse l'amour je suis à lille
non ça marche pas je veux dire oh
ça craint quoi je veux parler de la
puissance de la simplicité je me prends
la tête et je me suis souvenu une phrase
que je me dis quand il m'arrive des
trucs super chouette des trucs super dur
je me dis ah ouais c'est une blague de
l'univers et je passe beaucoup de temps
et que avec des lakotas c'est les
indiens des plaines qu'on appelait les
sioux et eux ils ont une phrase ils ont
une phrase avec laquelle ils vivent
ils disent on fait les choses très
sérieusement mais sans se prendre du
tout au sérieux et c'est un principe
très simple mais qui changent la vie
jeudi ya de la puissance dans la
simplicité
sourire manger un fruit délicieux
embrasser aider quelqu'un est raide et
prendre conscience que nous sommes tous
reliés meta couillet ou yacine
c'est une autre phrase lakota qui dit
nous sommes tous parents nous sommes
tous reliés
on n'est pas relié simplement entre
êtres humains l'un est relié avec les
pierres avec les nuages etc le vent avec
les océans les plantes les animaux qui
vivent dans la terre ce qui vole on est
constamment traversée par le mouvement
de la vie on est traversée par cette
continuité de souffle de vie et c'est ce
qui nous relie tous les uns aux autres
30 conscience de cette chose-là qui
finalement est très simple c'est à dire
on a besoin d'eau pour vivre qu'on est
traversé par l'eau ça nous relier aux
océans aux rivières au nuage à la pluie
on mange des plantes et des minéraux ça
nous relier aux pierres c'est un
principe très simple c'est un constat
c'est une réalité c'est comme ça d'en
prendre conscience et de se mettre à
vivre avec ça change ça change notre vie
ça change
positionnement c'est à dire qu'on vit
plus simplement enfermé avec soi même on
est relié avec un ensemble on vit dans
un monde qui est extrêmement fragmenté
en segmentant qui sépare les choses
c'est ça ou ça c'est bien c'est mal
c'est beau c'est moche et c'est vrai que
ça on a besoin de retrouver du lien de
retrouver du lien avec l'autre de
retrouver du lien avec soi même de
retrouver du lien avec son histoire avec
ses ancêtres de retrouver du lien avec
la biosphère avec l'environnement il ya
un mouvement de destructions massives
sur la planète
une malle répartition des richesses des
ressources qui est ridicule qui est
indécente et on n'arrive pas à trouver
de solutions non c'est pas qu'on
n'arrive pas à trouver de solutions
c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à les appliquer
on est dans une déficience de la jirs et
le challenge de notre époque c'est de
passer dans l'action et dans le
positionnement pas seulement agir agir
agir mais c'est aussi se positionner
apprendre à dire un vrai oui et un vrai
nom si tous à apprendre à dire oui
apprendre à dire non
pourtant c'est super compliqué alors la
question que je me pose dans mon
association dans mon quotidien
comment ça se fait alors qu on a à peu
près toutes les solutions même si
normand que certaines voix là pour faire
un monde qu'ils soient plus respectueux
de la vie plus respectueux des
différences
1 on a dépassé plus de la moitié des
espèces animales végétales disparu enfin
c'est un truc de fou
alors pourquoi on a des solutions alors
et et on n'arrive pas à les appliquer
alors je pars de constat c'est simple
c'est que ça veut dire qu'on est pris
par l'inertie se fait choper par
l'inertie
on n'y arrive pas là pour qu'on n'y
arrive pas à mon avis c'est parce que on
vit dans une société qui est super
infantilisante qui
génère un excès de confort en tout cas
pour toutes les sociétés qui ont accès à
la modernité
et puis qui nourrit et qui crée de la
peur en continu on vient au monde en
état de dépendance
on vient au monde en état de dépendance
aux adultes à ses parents pour survivre
on a besoin de l'autre et sept autres
ils décident pour nous ils nous donnent
à manger et s'occupe de nos besoins
primaires secondaires
donc on vient dans le monde
en s'en remettant à l'autre et on se
retrouve adulte et on se rend pas compte
qu'on continue à fonctionner comme ça et
on vit dans un système qui est très
infantile ''sans un système scolaire un
système économique un système politique
on a besoin d'apprendre à devenir des
adultes on a besoin d'apprendre à
s'autonomiser on est trop on est trop
dépendant de gros systèmes
alors comment ça marche pour devenir
adulte pour devenir autonome indépendant
ça veut dire en a besoin d'apprendre à
se séparer de ceux dont on n'a plus
besoin au moment où on en a plus besoin
un enfant il a besoin du sein maternel
et c'est une chose qui est délicieuse
qui est indispensable qui est tout ce
qui est agréable c'est ce dont il a
besoin à ce moment là est par contre il
va pas pouvoir continuer à vivre et à
grandir
s'il reste tout le temps au sein ou au
lait avec le biberon donc la vie c'est
une succession de séparation et on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'apprendre à séparer
des fonctionnements des modes dépenses
et des sensations qui sont plus
appropriés dont on n'a plus besoin
je dis souvent la vie c'est la vie c'est
pau c'est dur et ensuite on ma
c'est comme ça c'est une réalité on a du
mal avec la séparation pour changer les
choses
d'abord on a besoin de les observer
c'est à dire développer sa capacité
d'observation voir les choses telles
qu'elles sont pas tel quel on qu'on
aimerait qu'elle soit dans telles
qu'elles sont un souvent dans la sauce
normande associations jeudi l'un des
premiers actes mais dit un des premiers
acteurs militants c'est la méditation
cela parce que je suis hyper spirituelle
et non c'est parce qu'on a besoin de
tranquillité
on a besoin d'une tranquillité et cette
tranquillité on l'a pas on l'a pas parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à séparer au bon
moment de ce dont on doit se séparer
et si on prend toute toutes ces sommes
d'agitation individuel ça fait une
espèce de masse d'agitation sur la
planète qui fait comme une coulée une
coulée de boue puis qui détruit la vie
et la dignité sur son passage donc c'est
un devoir citoyen de trouver de la
tranquillité le bonheur c'est une chose
super relative aux cultures aux époques
mais si on a une chose en commun avec
tous les êtres humains tout le monde sur
la planète
quelle que soit l'époque quel que soit
sa culture sa religion
tout le monde a envie d'être joyeux en
bonne santé
tranquille c'est super simple pour ça on
a besoin d'apprendre à ses pas on a
besoin d'apprendre à lâcher ça fait de
la place pour du nouveau ca fait de la
place pour du plus grand alors la
personne connaît un peu plus parce que
c'est tellement bombardés par les médias
que c'est plus ça ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin de développer delà de
l'expérience et de la confiance
et puis oser il faut oser faire un saut
en avant
faut oser l'inconnu aux et le nouveau et
puis le confort à l'extrême ben là
j'étais à mayotte
la semaine dernière il ya plein de
bidonvilles plein de gens qui vivent
dans des cases en tôle et tout ça c'est
super dur
bref et j'hallucine parce qu'on voit à
travers les portes et jours ils ont un
canapé une télé ça c'est la modernité
c'est à dire en anesthésie on est
anesthésié on se laisse anesthésié avec
un excès de confort en fait qu'à pas
lieu d'être et et là ça veut dire qu'on
a aussi besoin de sortir de notre zone
de confort
mais sortir de sa zone de confort c'est
pas une perte c'est un élargissement
c'est une ouverture des possibles dans
les observations dans lé constat qu'on
peut faire c'est que aujourd'hui il ya
plein de mouvements sous jacent comme un
iceberg là et ces mouvements ils partent
de la société civile il parle de groupes
d'individus et souvent c'est un individu
qui tout seul il a dit non stop basta
voilà une bonne idée et il fait son truc
et souvent les gens ne suivent pas mais
il fait son truc il est vaste partie
simplement quoi ça ça me semble une
bonne chose je vais la faire je vais
expérimenter un faire les choses sans
trop se prendre au sérieux
ça aide à expérimenter et puis au bout
d'un moment il ya des gens qu'ils
rejoignent et tout ça ça se passe dans
des zones où il ya eu les
bouleversements économiques où il y
avait la crise économique 2008 tout ça
donc les gens ils ont été expulsés de
leur zone de confort du coup ils ont dû
se relier ils ont dû se relier ensemble
pour faire des choses nouvelles puisque
les solutions elles étaient plutôt
efficace donc aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
a besoin de faire cultiver des semences
locales
acheter un lombricomposteur créer des
coopératives de santé des coopératives
d'habitat monté sur son vélo faire
toutes ces petites choses arrêté
d'acheter des bouteilles en plastique
voilà si je me présentais se présenter
aux présidentielles je pense que
j'offrirai une bouteille une gourde là à
toute la france
ça qu'il faut faire
c'était chose simple mais c'est des
choses qui changent le monde
il faut oser son désir et oser se
séparer tout ce qu'on est quasiment
c'est parce qu'on l'a reçue ça vient de
la terre
ça vient du ciel ces informations qu'on
nous a donné c'est des vêtements qu'on a
acheté mais ça vient de la terre ça
vient de gens qui l'ont fabriqué la
nourriture ça vient des arts ça vient
des océans
presque tout ce qu'on aime c'est parce
qu'on nous l'a donnée et aujourd'hui on
passe dans l'ère du don dans l'ère du
partage c'est ça qu'on a à faire
même le prix libre c'est un truc qui
m'énerve puisque libre quant aux dires à
tue tête et dit bravo merci je le sais
ça veut dire ça réduit non c'est même
pas une histoire de prix libre on soit
dans le don
j'ai un ami africain est dit comme marc
tout à l'heure les deux il ya deux
choses qu'on perd pas quand on les donne
c'est l'amour et la connaissance je vous
remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]